Today is our Mega Makeover Hour.
We're teaming up with the biggest names
in the beauty industry to make over not one,
not two, not three,
but 25 amazing, deserving women
all show long.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I'm so excited to see how you guys all look.
But as we discussed,
we had a pep talk backstage, and you know what?
Beauty, where it really lives, is here
and here.
This is who we are.
This is what we've got.
And this is what we work with.
(audience cheering)
All right! I'm sending all the ladies backstage.
Are you ready?
(audience cheering)
All right, let's do this!
(upbeat music plays)
Please welcome, Drew Barrymore!
(audience cheering)
Hello everybody!
Hello everyone!
We are so excited that you are all here.
We've all been getting to know each other. And it's awesome.
This is our Mega Makeover Hour.
(audience cheering)
It's packed with big surprises, insider secrets,
plus those twenty-five transformations
that we're going to have to see to believe.
And we'll be checking in with them throughout the show.
They're getting their hair makeup and all new clothes.
Welcome back to hour Mega Makeover Hour!
It is time for the big reveal.
Here they are before.
(audience clapping)
And here they are now. Come on out ladies!
(upbeat music plays)
(audience cheering and clapping)
You look so beautiful. You look so beautiful.
Oh my gosh, you look so gorgeous.
Oh, you are looking hot.
(Drew Barrymore gasping)
You look so beautiful.
Oh my goodness.
I love that.
Oh my god!
Your eyebrows look amazing. I love them.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa.
Wow!
Oh my god, you look so beautiful.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I mean, I am just so happy
to be in a sisterhood with you guys,
and it's not just about the hair, makeup and wardrobe.
It is in your energy.
(audience clapping)
Wow.
Well, I want to say thank you to The Gap
for dressing all of our women today.
I mean,
(audience clapping)
this does not look like it came from one establishment.
I love that. You could do all of this in one place?
I'm there.
And they're also giving all of our women gift cards today,
so they can go back and shop for themselves.
(audience cheering and clapping)
$200 gift cards each.
That's going to be great.
And I really want to thank all of the women
from Ready to Empower,
(whooping and cheering)
Yes!
A World of Pink,
(audience clapping)
914Cares,
And the Theodore D. Young Community Center.
(audience clapping)
And let's not forget about Food Bank for NYC.
We appreciate all that you do.
And that's why we'll be making a donation
to all of your organizations.
(audience clapping)
And absolutely.
I just want to thank this amazing dream team.
To me, I am star-struck by you guys,
because I'm always watching what you do out in the world
with these amazing people,
but you are amazing people.
And you know what? It is about the way you feel.
And we have got to make ourselves feel good.
We've got to make each other feel good.
And I think that this has been very powerful for me
to see a large group.
(audience clapping)
The world isn't easy out there.
And if we can have this kind of goodness in here,
it gives me the faith and the belief that I need
to just keep being positive and optimistic.
So thank you to everybody.
Chris Appleton!
Brandice Daniel!
Zanna Roberts Rassi!
And the Young Emperors:
Nelson Tiberghien and Isabelle Chaput!
Wow, we'll see you all tomorrow.
(cheerful music)